so this is the second time that the
advisory Council on the misuse of drugs
has come back to report that the nitrous
oxide isn't so harmful that it needs to
be banned the government had asked the
advisory Council which is the the body
that advises the government on these
issues to come back and to look into
whether or not it is that harmful it has
come back to say it's not harmful enough
to Warrant a ban instead it's
recommending additional measures to
tackle the illegitimate sale of nitrous
oxide and to educate the public better
on both immediate and the long-term
harms of inhaling nitrous oxide and
misusing it now to carry out this report
The Advisory Council looked at a number
of issues they took into consideration
the health harms of nitrous oxide you
might have seen Sky News investigation
last week during which time we spoke to
a 20 year old man who had ended up in a
wheelchair because of his habits of
inhaling nitrous oxide um the body also
looked at the links between nitrous
oxide misuse and antisocial Behavior
Associated crime and impact on local
communities and also the environmental
impact we know lots of people have
complained about seeing you know dozens
of these spent canisters just discarded
um on the side of roads now the report
says that the harms aren't so bad that
it warrants being banned it says that to
ban it would be disproportionate when
you look at who's using it and it also
said says that to bannett would produce
significant burdens for the people who
do use it legitimately nitrous oxide is
a gas that is used by hospitals and
dental surgeries it's a pain relief it
has a pain relief function it's also
used sometimes in the catering industry
and some people use it at home in cream
canisters to whip up and to make whipped
cream so that's the advice from The
Advisory Council the misuse of drugs we
wait to hear what the government will
say in its response we understand that
the Home Secretary does want to ban
nitrous oxide but the it will be
difficult to push this through because
this is as I say the second time that
this body has come back to say that it
isn't as harmful to Warrant being banned
and so it remains a psychoactive
substance it wants it to remain as a
psychoactive substance and that means it
is illegal to sell it for recreational
purposes but it is not illegal to inhale
it